[Musik]
hey leute heute machen wir eine richtig
leckere und erfrischende erdbeer rolle
und zwar ist die no big points im
handumdrehen zaubern mit ganz ganz
wenigen schritten und er braucht weniger
als zehn zutaten jackson nachgezählt
zeigt euch mal schnell
ich habe hier bitter lemon es könnt ihr
auch bis weit ersetzen aber ich liebe
bitter nehmen dann habe ich hier
magerquark doppel ram frischkäse und
sahne fest hier habe ich zum süßen
puderzucker
außerdem ist noch kalte schlagsahne
frisch aus dem kühlschrank hier frische
erdbeeren schön fein geschnitten in
mundgerechte stücke und vanille extrakt
und außerdem benötigen wir
löffelbiskuits und die die uns jetzt so
ein bisschen länger verfolgen die kennen
die vorgehensweise vielleicht schon
erinnert euch an die bananen rolle
die so gut angekommen dass ich mir
dachte jetzt zu diesem sommer muss
irgendwas neues her
und auch in der gleichen art aber die
creme ist ein bisschen anders wir fangen
jetzt aber wieder mit dem löffel bizkit
an und wichtig ist dass ihr das jetzt
eindruck neben die leckere flüssigkeit
bei mir bitter lemon oder in dem spiel
könnt natürlich auch mehr schnee aber
glaubt mir probiert aus so schmeckt so
erfrischend das wird jetzt hier rein und
dann tun wir das für zwei sekunden ein
12 und gibt das mit der zucker seite
nach unten hier einmal auf die folie
[Musik]
und ich mache die rolle jetzt genauso
lang wie in den bananen rollen video
nämlich zwölf proben und zwölf kekse
unten und falls ihr euch jetzt gefragt
habe warum ich die zucker seite nach
unten gebe wenn jetzt die seite nehmen
würdet dann wird das eine folie
festkleben
wichtig ist auch dass wir unbedingt
folie drunter macht damit er später auch
schön auf rollen können und das ist
wirklich ein kinderspiel
übrigens wo ich schon mal quatschen im
letzten video haben so erinnert sich
auch da haben wir den schritt ganz
gezeigt wie wir die folie abnehmen das
war so kinderleicht habe gar nicht
drüber nachgedacht einfach nicht
aufgenommen wir haben vergessen und
diesmal kann nicht unendlich zeigen weil
einige schlimme ist doch gar nicht so
kinder meist kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen
aber heute kann es euch an endlich
zeigen so meine lieben die
löffelbiskuits sind soweit vorbereitet
das ganze muss jetzt für zwei stunden in
den kühlschrank voll sich jetzt fragt
warum die lange wartezeit
das liegt einfach daran dass die
löffelbiskuits richtig schön fest werden
müssen und so dass man sich später
anrollen kann jetzt würden sie noch
zerbrechen deshalb eben die wartezeit
aber wir machen in der zwischenzeit die
creme also sehen wir uns gleich schon
wieder und für die creme werden jetzt
ganz einfach alle zutaten die hier seht
ist dass die abwägung später erste zum
in einer großen schüssel miteinander
verrührt und dafür nehme ich jetzt mein
handwerk gering
das geht natürlich auch ansonsten mit
der küchenmaschine aber das spare ich
mir jetzt einfach und ich mache das ja
immer gerne so dass ich alles in einer
schüssel miteinander aufschlage das
funktioniert aber nur wenn alle zutaten
ganz kalt sind also ganz frisch aus dem
kühlschrank kommen
[Musik]
und das war es auch schon nur ein paar
minütchen aufschlagen wie gesagt an den
zutaten kalt sind dann ist es auch gar
kein problem
und jetzt die erdbahn einfach eingeben
und dann nimmt ihr euch am besten sauber
und hebt es schön unter sobald die
kürzer dann vorbei ist könnt ihr die
creme direkt auf euren löffelbiskuits
geben so ein bisschen glatt streichen
aber es muss nicht perfekt sein wenn
jetzt wollen wir das ganze ein
und da hilft uns jetzt die
frischhaltefolie und dadurch dass jetzt
die kekse eingeweicht sind unschön
festgenommen sind können wir das auch
ganz einfach einräumen
[Musik]
seit für mich die erdbeer rolle
aufgerollt und dann ganz einfach die
frischhaltefolie entfernt das problem
ist und es macht einen strich durch die
rechnung nicht nur dass es draußen zu
erhalten ist werden wir überall lichter
aber bei euch zuhause gelingt dass
bestimmte noch einfacher und jetzt habe
ich mir pistazien in meinem mixa kleine
mal das gebe ich jetzt auch drüber weil
ich bin ehrt und pistazien passen
richtig gut und die pistazien ich komme
aus der türkei aus gaziantep und die
gibt es auch bei mir im shop genauso wie
viele andere sachen wie ich jetzt in dem
video verwendet habt ihr verlinke ich
euch dann auch in die infobox
[Musik]
und fertig ist die erdbeer rolle
ihr könnt das ganze jetzt nach machen
und bis zu drei tage im kühlschrank
aufbewahren nämlich so lange hält sie
sich dann frisch aber ich glaube nicht
dass die so lange hält ganz ehrlich
schmeckt so lecker so frisch und vor
allem leicht perfekt für das wetter und
für den sommer in der infobox findet ihr
alle genauen mengenangaben hinterlässt
im video ein like und ein kommentar und
abonniert main kanal kostenlos dann
verpasst ihr zukünftig auch nichts mehr
und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal
auf die küste zu
[Musik]